ladies and gentlemen I have done it if
you didn't know I have made it to the
top I am King of Kings I have reached
the elite of the elite levels of success
I have my own book that was not written
by me Philip
wall knee has written a book about me I
was not made aware that this was
happening it's almost as if my
permission wasn't asked for I don't even
know if my permission was necessary I
don't know the legality of someone
making a book about me without my
permission
just email my lawyer a link to this
video because I'm a little curious
because this was not free this was sold
or at least I'm assuming it was sold
because Ethan got this for me from
Amazon I'm not gonna provide a link to
it because that'd be weird but the
series is known as top video gamers in
the world the trademark to trademark
mark markiplier Fishbach star YouTube
gamer star YouTube gamer with ten
billion plus views well it's already out
of date mr. wooly you need to do your
research because I forgot I'm not
recording my desktop at the moment I'll
just say the number and then Lexie and
put it on screen oh so gently just lay
it lay it on the screen like a sweet
summer's kiss
I have 12 billion 567 million nine
hundred and forty two thousand six
hundred and ninety-six views as of this
word that's not a word as of that noise
that came out of my mouth that's how
much I have so mr. Walley put up a
picture of mr. wall nee mr. wall D you
have some explaining
I demand an updated edition
I demand that this be taking down I'm
not sure what I'm gonna demand yet
because I have not read it yet so what
we're gonna do today is we're gonna go
through this book
now I've intentionally not read this
i-i've skimmed the first few pages I
skimmed a little bit inside but I've not
read this we are gonna go on this
journey together I'm going to review
this book so that you don't have to but
I am in league league with these names
here the likes of Al Rubeus Garmendia
and ninja that's the kind of elite club
that I'm currently in right now these
people here just my pals so we're gonna
go through this book and we're gonna see
what it's all about because I'm not
aren't sure what it is all about I mean
it's probably about me oh that's a great
picture just just right off the bat the
first picture that you see when you open
it up I don't know who took this but I
know where it is it's at a Comic Con
2016 one of the most hellish adventures
of signing things I've ever done in my
life and I've done a lot of those
alright it was March in 2015 and mark
Edward Fishbach was in the hospital my
age starting here this isn't even the
first time I was in the hospital if you
were to start this you'd started the
tumor surgery the event proved to not be
serious fortunately but it was unusual
for a 26 year old in otherwise good
health I mean not really if you had
mentioned that I had been in the
hospital that tumor removed it would not
be that unusual
well his driver's license might say Mark
Fischbach you have no idea what my
driver's license says is better known to
the world by his online handle
markiplier he's an immensely popular
YouTube gamer and on my Star he asked
the nurse to hold the camera while he
gave an update on his health situation
no I asked my mom who is a retired nurse
so technically I'll give you a point put
a point on the board for wall me we're
gonna do play wrong answers and then
technically correct answers because I
don't think that they're gonna be any
absolute correct answers I'm really just
hunting for the inaccuracies and in the
in the story that is my life the online
star made his name with numerous let's
play videos that make use of his oddball
sense of humor technically correct I'll
put that up there has more than 20
million subscribers on his YouTube
channel okay we're in accuracy along
with the number of years it's outdated
on the number of subs by five million
we're up to twenty five million and God
there is such difference get it right in
the hospital mark has a tuba business
among teenagers and gamers two separate
people's he is one of the most popular
and most watched content creators online
this is correct yes sometimes a little
wild and always funny and engaging
absolutely great thank you for getting
that right wall nee has become one of
the most influential pop culture figures
of his generation
that okay here we go pop culture figures
influential I don't think I could tell
any single one of my fan base to do
literally anything I don't know how much
influence I have when I can't even get
them to say like a video or if I LK if I
asked you guys to comment the letter B
you would shift gears and start typing
the letter e not only despite me but to
go for a dead mean that's how
influential I am people will go out of
the way to do the opposite of what I
want them to do so that's this book in
the market Blair and some of his
youtuber and gamer peers are the pop
stars for a new generation no it is a
generation that is always online and all
an online fame can be short-lived
I've been doing it for eight years so
nope viral stars can explode onto the
scene and seemingly fade away by the
weekend technically correct it takes a
certain type of unique star power to
gain the kind of fame markiplier has not
only maintain it but grow it well I'm a
big idiot so I don't know what kind of
star power I have guess we voices oh and
a huge boot so you know markiplier has
also never been afraid of trying new
things are experimenting with new
formats he has more recently started to
branch out into comedy despite setbacks
personal losses including friends and
family and the difficulties of being a
career on
entertainer Mark Clark continues to
thrive if you saw how is my day-to-day
life you would not say that I am
thriving I have a living a good life
don't get me wrong good life but
thriving mmm the jury's out on that one
in the 1980s Mark's father a career US
Army soldier met his mother in South
Korea they later moved around see that
the grammar here makes it seem like my
dad met his own mom in South Korea
because you're saying the possessive
marks father
so father is the subject a career US
Army soldier met his mother his would
refer to the subject I want to be okay
this isn't the wrong call my dad did not
meet his own mother in South Korea that
would be odd in 1987 they welcomed their
first child into the world
Jason Thomas Fishbach called Thomas he
said that on June 28th 1989 mark what
Edward was born at Tripler Army Medical
Center on the island of Oahu in the
state capital Honolulu he was a big baby
ten pounds and 3 ounces 4.6 kilograms
this is all right wait no correct I was
and M a big baby
not long after mark was born his father
retired from the military after 23 years
they moved all the way to Cincinnati
Ohio where Mark's father would work as
an illustrator in publishing wrong he
worked as a layout artist not an
illustrator he probably used Adobe
Illustrator I don't know he worked as a
layout artist wrong all right you know
there's a lot to go through we're not
gonna read this whole book so I'm just
gonna start skimming because there's
gonna be a lot of incorrect information
oh I think I've talked about this in the
video where Ethan showed this to me by
divorce
ups and downs yeah because there's ups
to divorce two Christmases two birthdays
those are the ups that's it everything
else mark thought his mother in
particular was unhappy with the marriage
especially since their father was a good
deal older than her they mostly tried to
ignore it
their parents tried to patch things up
eventually however divorce became
inevitable that's cool
I think what happened is they just
watched my draw my life because their
own literally only referencing my draw
my life which at this point is outdated
information I made that video in like
2013 and frankly I didn't even know how
to make a video like that at the time
okay it's so weird someone because their
talk there's a section about my dad's
death in here very weird to see someone
else write about this and have
information in here that isn't true I
mean the broad strokes are true but it's
very clear that someone wrote this with
the intent to fill in the gaps about how
I felt about certain things and that's
where I kind of like draw the line is
like sure write a Wikipedia article
about whatever you want but if you're
gonna write a book and sell it for money
don't put emotions in my face don't
stuff emotions down my throat that's
that's a that's a that's a no-no mr.
wall knee okay whatever the entirety of
my personal life has been condensed into
six pages which is more than I would
have put it down to I would have said I
was born a big fat baby I grew up a big
fat baby my parents got a big fat
divorce and then I became a big fat
adult that's what happened to me around
the time that you Fischbach started at
Fischbach the online video streaming and
video sharing platform known as YouTube
was only a few years old and it
officially launched in February of 22
2005 Google bought the service in 2006
seeing its enormous potential in
addition a new generation of Yatta Yatta
oh my god who cares about YouTube enter
Mark Fischbach gamer an engineering
major he was unhappy for reasons beyond
his father's death this is four years
after my dad died I can guarantee you I
did not carry that with me for four
years oh my god
his typical office jobs where he was
doing work he was not passionate about
we're bringing his spirits down all
right you got me on that one that's a
technical correct he needed something
else no actually at the time you have
not gotten to the crux of the issue at
this point you are wrong because
I had no ambition to do more so wrong-o
wrong-o wrong-o you have make it seem
like I was destined for YouTube which I
definitely was not let's be very clear
books like this often make things seem
like they were always destined they
right after the fact so they write with
the assumption that it was like always
if my intention to do something like
that which it was not it was not there
was a catalyst moment which cost me to
do that which I think a lot of people
when they're trying to make stories
about people whether Victor faction or
fickt fiction and the faction whether
it's Victor fact and this kind of hits
on the fact that this is a little
fiction no I had no ambition to be a
youtuber until 2012 I didn't even really
think about YouTube as a whole until
who'da thunk tit Oh weird yeah no I was
not always destined to be a youtuber I
was gonna be an office monkey till the
day I died Fishbach decided to leave
college putting engineer behind him for
good
but when did they do this
he was also dying to leave standard off
his jobs to break out into something
more exciting
what no at one point a medical emergency
landed him in the hospital here it is
constant pain his side was revealed to
be as appendix which is swelled up
dangerously and needed to be removed
doctors also noted that the fist-sized
tumor in his adrenal gland that would
have to come out after his hospital
ordeal he brought a video camera to use
for video no
no no between my surgery and YouTube
there is a four month gap I did not jump
from surgery to YouTube because that
really wasn't even my thought process I
thought about writing I thought about
game design and thought about comic
making I thought about art I thought
about a bajillion things I found YouTube
it was not a goal it was never a goal I
never wanted to be a youtuber and yet
Here I am
I do now nothing a devoted and serious
gamer Fischbach was also a natural in
front of the camera no lick see and pull
up footage of my first time that I was I
had a face cam it was like amnesia some
custom story why am I not recording my
desktop yeah okay it's it's amnesia
abduction part 12 hello everybody and
welcome back to the amnesia custom story
abduction wait who's that handsome guy
up in the corner it me yeah finally got
my webcam so you guys can see my looks
of horror Dvorak that I looked Asian
people are still shocked to this day
that I location don't know whether it is
it is cuz I am alright phoenix from the
ashes hmm really means the phoenix from
the ashes oh my goodness oh my goodness
500,000 subscribers yep that happened
Wilfred worse - other characters sure
did sure had those charity livestreams
yep I do that quick hit facts literally
it says quick hit facts alright let's do
this
god damn it he is known for frequently
changing his hair color and his dyed his
hair blue black technically yes red pink
and other colors no those were as a
result of me swimming in the pool Marc
Blair says he suffers from a ton about a
phobia which is a fear of mannequins and
similar dolls yes kids visited his
mother's native country Korea on three
separate occasions now five on
livestream marklar once told his fans he
had been diagnosed with mild attention
deficit hyperactivity disorder it's not
mild to a fish Mark's favorite phrases
while vlogging or but either way
well alright then don't call me out like
that no hang on like stop putting
good point in the technically correct
form that no that's right you forgot
about so anyway you can't call me out
like this book you can market flowers
mark Blair's famous logo digital letter
M with his trademark pink mustaches all
over his creative content it is also
featured on the hoodies dog leashes
t-shirts coffee cups and other
merchandise fans can buy on his online
shop which all goes to charity by the
way a few of his close collaborators are
his friends stylish add Wade Barnes Bob
my skin's and Ethan Nestor darling shad
serves as markiplier I shouldn't be
laughing as hard as I should for the
record no is not and has never been my
manager I don't that that is so funny
no no we talked about this in the in the
other video it's a picture of me and
Aimee its picture of me and Aimee a
while it won't focus there we go it's a
picture okay well yeah there we go okay
it's a picture of me and Aimee and the
caption is markiplier and a friend
regardless of what he does markiplier
has continued to welcome legions of fans
into his community where they have been
entertained comforted and made to feel
at home whatever the future holds for
him he vows to keep working hard
expanding his horizons and making his
young fans laugh cry think and enjoy
themselves well that's nice that's nice
Dan Don that's a pretty good one I
appreciate that but also is this allowed
I have no idea honestly I don't really
care meanwhile full of inaccuracies like
it's clear that they went to some links
to tried to do research but you know if
they dug a little deeper I guess but
there's only so much information out
there about my life even though I've put
out 4700 videos talking about my life
but you know you can only get so much
out of that there's no way you get the
little speck
my life and they put my old life in a
book there we go that's it have you ever
wanted to know about me why not just
watch my videos cuz I talk about my life
all the time you can get to know me as a
person instead of whatever that book
tried to pay me into being okay anyway I
got nothing else to say about this
there's books about other people I guess
I don't know why but there are lik see
it figure out some way to wrap this up
you got this okay you got I'll just yeah
I'll be on my phone you figure out how
this video ends put like you know yeah
yeah like this video if you like this
video but not me I don't take me saying
that just you got it
[Music]
ah cool good good job lick Singh you did
it I'm proud of you unless you didn't
did you anyway thank you everybody so
much for watching as always I'll see you
in the next video bye bye